this has i think the best the best score  here  or one percentage at the very least  because then you have the amount of  pieces oh the chessboard  five more okay go go go  i'm on my way  we'll take it  msb  i'm starting to  sort of get the advantage here you can  maybe go bc but it's not comfortable  okay at least i can take this  and win two pieces for  it's not a massive of advantage but it's  it's an advantage still and if i can  consolidate i should win  i think i have consolidated  which means that i should win  c5 is the best try  this is no good  and we win the queen  vamos almost i'm in the lead  hey  nice i don't have a nice score anymore  but or i didn't have